tu n'es pas Peter Parker, je suis tellement confus
en ce moment
que le sort que tu as acheté a commencé à
attirer des visiteurs de tous les univers,
le multivers est réel
[Applaudissements]
ils meurent tous en combattant Spider-Man, il doit y
avoir un autre moyen, n'est-ce pas
?  Je suis un danger pour notre univers,
tout est de ma faute. Je ne peux pas sauver
tout le monde.
Spider-Man ne peut pas rentrer à la maison au cinéma le
17 décembre. Depuis que j'ai été mordu par
cette araignée, je n'ai
eu qu'une semaine où ma vie m'a
semblé normale.  Quand tu as découvert
Peter
ce sort que tu as bâclé, il a commencé à
attirer des visiteurs de tous les univers, ce
qui se passe, ils commencent à
arriver et je ne peux pas l'arrêter
Spider-Man, pas de chemin à la maison quand tu
penses, hé, je suis sur le point de le faire.  pour faire quelque chose
qui pourrait briser l'univers, dirigez-le par
nous la prochaine fois dans les salles le 17 décembre
c'est Peter laisse un message ouais Peter
c'est heureux
qui sont ces gars hein
un des gars a fait de la boue qu'est-ce qui se
passe rappelle-moi
quand je ferme  Ce sort, nous avons commencé à
recevoir des visiteurs de tous
les univers, le
multivers est réel,
c'est qu'un dinosaure est sorti
en salles le 17 décembre.